asperges et de désinfectants ces
travailleurs migrants tentent de quitter
l'état de l'uttar pradesh
ils sont plusieurs milliers à avoir pris
la route le long des voies rapides
déserte
certains s'apprêtent à marcher plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres pour rejoindre
leur village d'origine
on atteindra nos villages à pied
d'environ huit jours ma ville natale et
à environ 500 kilomètres d'ici il nous
faudra donc environ une semaine pour y
arriver
ces migrants issus des régions
intérieures sont venus gagner leur vie à
new delhi ce loin dernier recensement il
représenterait environ 30% de la
population
ils seraient plus de 6,3 millions dans
la capitale indienne pour nombre d'entre
eux sont payés à la journée mais le
confinement nationale les a privés de
ressources du jour au lendemain
maintenant il n'y a plus de travail nous
n'avons plus un son
c'est pour ça qu'il est préférable que
nous rentrions dans nos villages c'est
pourquoi nous sommes venus ici
si nous ne trouvons pas d'autocars nous
irons à pied comme à rome des dizaines
de milliers de travailleurs migrants
tentent leur chance de trouver un car
pour retourner dans leur ville natale
avant que le pays ne s'arrête pour les
trois prochaines semaines
mais cet exode soulève des craintes de
propagation du virus
beaucoup se sont retrouvés entassés par
les autorités dans des bus ou des
campements de secours pour l'heure le
gouvernement indien débloquer d'1 3
milliard de dollars pour venir en aide à
ces travailler en iran